the series of debates on the future of  Europe continues this week the Danish  Prime Minister Lars Locka Rasmussen  exchanges views with members Parliament  wants to reduce the maximum length of  temporary border checks in the Schengen  area to one-year with initial checks  capped at two months some countries  reintroduce checks in 2015 following the  migrant crisis members look at the  progress of five Western Balkan nations  on their paths towards EU membership  developments in Serbia Kosovo the Former  Yugoslav Republic of Macedonia Albania  and Montenegro will be discussed how can  European jobs be protected from the  challenges of globalization members will  consider changes to the European global  adjustment fund which has saved  thousands of European jobs the EU funds  dozens of research projects that improve  our daily lives from environmental  protection to nanotechnology they will  be in the spotlight on Tuesday during a  high-level conference  [Music]